well breaking overnight a surprising  announcement from the Grammys this is a  big one the organization is without a  leader just 10 days before the ceremony  I'm so excited to be here with you this  morning it's my first Grammy  that's Deborah Dugan the first female  president of the Recording Academy at  the Grammys nomination ceremony in  November she was removed from her post  only five months after taking the job in  a statement to CBS News the Academy  cited a quote allegation of misconduct  by a senior female member of the team it  did not provide details the organization  has now hired independent investigators  to look into the claim in a report in  Variety magazine overnight sources close  to the situation claimed Duggan's ouster  may have been a coup by Academy veterans  resistant to changes she was trying to  make we've reached out to Dugan but have  not heard back the Grammy ceremony airs  on CBS On January 26 CBS entertainment  declined to comment